aux classes et investigations car
camille arrive à 20h50 précise pour
l'instant place investigations c'est
parti d'une gueule dans le paf
tous les jours il ya des clashs comme un
i que ce soit sur twitter que ce soit
sur boubou que ce soit sur un stade ce
soit partout il ya toujours des clashs
et hier télé loisirs a dévoilé un
premier extrait de l'interview sans
filtre avec gérard lanvin gérard lanvin
qui était chroniqueur noté pp qui doit
nous vois mal de fois qu'ils étaient
producteurs de julien courbet et julie
et surtout on est super sympa avec lui
et dès qu'il fait une interview ils se
sont butés nous mettre des cartouches
alors je sais pas ce qui là où ils nous
aiment et ils envie de revenir mais ils
n'osent pas le dire ou es nous aiment
pas et qui nous lâchent
ou bien il a un problème et je vous dit
hier il a clashé certains chroniqueurs
dont un de mes préférés
maxime guide regardez maxime gainey il a
une vraie il a une vraie qualité il
s'entend que c'est un des chroniqueurs
tu es belle baie non mais je sais rien
de vous
en même temps je suis en total mais pas
gentil alors oui c'est vraiment bête
c'est pas parce qu'on est connue quand
j'ai du talent et à linverse sais pas ce
qu'on a connu qu'on n'en a pas
directement pas lui quand il ne les
émissions j'aime beaucoup ce genre mais
personne ne savait qui serviront grand
public devrait bien des cas mais si les
milieux pour ce qui personne savait
québec gérard louvin donc ces bêtes
devient noir geôliers qui est très bon
là vraiment il lui qui fait des trucs
vraiment bien ensemble et comment cette
cause du grand public mais il aurait pu
lui dire la même chose voilà moi je suis
très en colère quand gérard louvin reste
qu'à deux discours coloré nouveau en
dehors c'est vrai nous parlons quand il
vous appelle il est charmant il veut
bosser et c et d qui fait ni d'interview
indesign
il s'attaque au pauvre maxime qui sait
pas comment lui répliquer en toute
amitié maxime
c'est gentil maxi 6 décembre au matin je
suis la ville je sais où il habite alors
je vais dire en toute amitié gérard
ferme ta gueule
ok ce n'est pas 10 du producteur des
hôpitaux du producteur que tu as été ya
20 ans alors il y pas il a par contre
parler de certains chroniqueurs en biens
notamment gilles verdez valoir tirade il
a dit les merveilles que telle était au
début on ne parlait que média y avait
que les experts médias gilles verdez
jean-michel mais regardez regardez bien
vu une vraie équipe de jeunes acteurs
professionnels
bon et maintenant je connais personne à
bord vers des bombes et naïm qui a eu un
problème de santé et jean michel maire
mais c'est vrai que les têtes sont un
peu trop nouvelles jambes mais attention
ça correspond aux jeunes qui rien au
final
alors il a été sympa oui voilà il dit
quelque chose on peut pas lui reprocher
de dire ce qu'il pense et dit qu'il
n'est plus en phase parce que c'est
peut-être générationnel peut pas lui
reprocher de dire qu'il est plus dans la
cible les mesures mises aux cartouches
il a dit il a dit dans une interview qui
regarder des émissions
je vais vous dire la vérité parce que je
ne serai sans fil cette année n'en
attendait que vous voulez la vérité
il se trouve que hier on était en
réunion comme on le fait tous les jours
avec cyril où on rigole beaucoup et il a
appris gérard llovera et fait quelques
déclarations qu est ce qu a fait série
la plus au téléphone est fait oui alors
gérard ces séries comment vas-tu glee a
très bien tu dis quelque chose
pas du tout et le mec avait rendez-vous
aujourd'hui avec lui avec vous et vous
avez purement et simplement annulé son
rendez vous et sauf certain que gérard
est un grand pro sachant qu'il a rendez
vous avec vous donc aujourd'hui nous
fracasse vous fracasse je vois pas
l'intérêt alors j'espère que c'est ce
qui s'est passé et surtout confuse et
qu'est-ce que dali dit j'ai rien dit
alors soit il a après parce qu'on n'a
pas bien servi il a dit qu'il regardait
l'émission convieront voilà qu'il
voulait pas il n'y a pas de dire je
viens pas dans touche pas à mon poste
pour contre l'église mais ça fait on se
déguise ceux qui veulent se déguisent et
nous on est dans la rigole avec ceux qui
se prennent au sérieux ils ont pas leur
place de téléphone il vous dit pas ce
qu'il dit pas la même chose de ce qu'il
a dit dans le dos là bas mais c'est ça
sur moi pas un mot un bonnes questions
afin qu'il est venu ici c'était pour la
mort de john est super il avait été
excellent nom l'année cours de l'an
passé à la presse après nous ici
toujours la liberté d'expression donc
après tout pourquoi pas il a le droit de
dire qu'il préfère le quotidien au
regard des quotidiens mais il veut la
lumière en revanche kas qui est un oui
moi insupportable c'est qu'ils disent
qu'il faut forcément été les plus vains
donc en fait il faut être quoi il faut
être rachid arhab bruno masure et gérard
louvin pour avoir le droit d'avoir un
regard ou un point de vue sur la
télévision
oui c'est ça c'est surtout que c'est la
famille si les repas de famille tu as
quelqu'un qui dit tu es vraiment un
connard c'est toujours blesson parce que
il fait partie de la famille enfin on
peut penser que c'était partie de la
famille vous savez sont bons dans l'air
du temps de crème de cracher dans la
soupe pour faire le buzz est donc le mot
qu'il faut un peu de soupe vous avez dit
connard mais je parle pas de vous chers
fouet l être quand même pas de ma mère
fut déchets au coup d'envoi oui très
d'innovative mais juste vers louvain a
est déconnecté de la réalité
il ne me connaît pas ni en cas de procès
qu'il n'a pas regardé l'émission depuis
le 1er janvier 2010 est donc de l'année
dernière je crois qu'il est juste un peu
nostalgique de la période durant
laquelle il était chroniqueur simplement
voilà c'est ça j'ai dit ça vous énerve
qui veut dire que c'est de la méchanceté
gratuite
je veux dire c'est vraiment pour faire
parler lui à mon avis et ça m'a pas du
tout